efectivamente la prensa francesa le
pidió a Emanuel macron que diera su
mensaje a la ciudadanía de Francia que
vive su primer día de huelga y de
manifestaciones como bien lo estábamos
viendo el presidente de la república
francesa afirmó que mientras que la
huelga y las manifestaciones son
derechos democráticos Él espera que
estos se desarrollen sin ningún
disturbio ni violencia y que no causen
un perjuicio a la ciudadanía francesa
sin embargo ha dicho macron que esta
disconformidad contra la reforma de las
pensiones tendría que haberse
manifestado en las elecciones generales
del año pasado presidenciales del año
pasado puesto que esta reforma ya
formaba parte de su programa electoral y
que la ciudadanía tendría que haberse
expresado en las urnas terminó
recordando que esta reforma es justa y
responsable que de hecho Francia está
rezagada con respecto a otros países
europeos y que en una sociedad con cada
vez una mayor esperanza de vida Esta
reforma hay que hacerla hablemos ahora
de este encuentro ya se conocen las
conclusiones que resultó de esta cita
entre macron y Sánchez
resultó el llamado tratado de Barcelona
un tratado que refuerza políticamente
unos lazos ciudadanos culturales
históricos que existen desde
generaciones entre España y Francia y
que equiparará las relaciones políticas
de Francia y España con las que Francia
mantiene con Alemania o Italia porque
recordemos este es el tercer acuerdo de
amistad y cooperación Que firma Francia
y el segundo para España que también lo
tiene con Portugal algunas medidas
concretas pues una bastante poco
habitual Y es que cada tres meses un
ministro del gabinete de cada gobierno
será invitado al consejo de ministros
del país Aliado y es algo que se rotará
entre países y entre ministros ha habido
también acuerdos de seguridad y se
crearán grupos de trabajo en cuestiones
migratorias y en cuestiones para reabrir
unos pasos fronterizos terrestres que
permanecían cerrados desde 2021 sán hizo
mención a la ley en contra de la
inflación de Estados Unidos y dice que
se alegran de que baiden apueste por la
transición verde pero no a Costa de la
desindustrialización de Europa y
brevemente termino un claro mensaje
europeísta con alguna mención en el
tratado de Barcelona a las relaciones
con América Latina para reforzar estas
un tratado este de Barcelona que ambos
líderes han calificado de histórico
gracias